let's go to the phone 617 830 4750 is
the number let's start with our first
caller from the 989 area code caller
what's your name and where you calling
from hi my name is derek i'm calling
from michigan and um mmm I've been
wanting to call him for a while because
I had a question but I would forget
about it so i thought i'd ask you about
like um how do you feel about ignoring
Trump well I mean I think that I
understand the idea which is listen
Trump feeds off of attention if you
ignore Trump he actually a much of what
Trump does is a reaction to the
attention paid to him at least as far as
social media is concerned and arguably
even in terms of policy but there's no
real way to just say we're going to
ignore everything the President of the
United States does you know I understand
the instinct but I think that its
service to do that well I mean like
maybe not the media but like say the
next Democratic campaigns against them
it's going to be really it's going to be
really really you know easy for them to
do some like Hillary Clinton which is
make a campaign of outrage and character
assassination instead of talking about
policy what if no matter how much crazy
stuff she says like all I want to deport
everybody that is and why or something
some people like that it would be really
easy for someone to view it like outrage
like hey that's crazy but what if we
just attack him on policy and just
completely don't give him the
satisfaction of freaking everybody out
yeah but you know the problem is where's
the line right because his policies are
so insane that in order to attack him on
policy you're going to be sort of doing
it in a way where it sounds like hey
this guy's nuts because the policies are
so nuts it's an interesting idea I
understand the instinct I just don't
know how to apply it in a practical way
yeah anyways uh thanks guys alright
thanks so much really appreciate the
call always great to hear from our
callers